an unclaimed rocket was fired at Israel
early on Thursday
the Israeli Army then fired shells into
Lebanon
it was yet another cross-border incident
that was yet again quickly contained
open areas were targeted in a sign that
neither side wanted a major flare-up but
the timing told another story
we are seeing more and more unifications
of uh of groups
responding to Israeli aggressions and
Palestine and we're seeing this is
happening in Gaza we're seeing this
happening in South and Lebanon and we
can expect that more retaliations to
develop around Israeli borders
unifying the front that's a new military
tactic established by the iranian-backed
Lebanese armed group Hezbollah it's
repeatedly warned of a multi-front
assault by Iran's allies across the
region
this week Israel launched airstrikes
against Iranian Targets in Syria and a
major assault against the occupied West
Bank Town of Janine
then came a ramming and stabbing attack
in Tel Aviv a rocket attack from
Southern Gaza to Northern Israel and now
the rocket attack from Southern Lebanon
this incident comes at a sensitive time
in the region and in an area that saw
tensions earlier this week the United
Nations peacekeeping Forces urging
restraint and calling on both sides to
avoid further escalation
and there is a possibility Hezbollah has
accused Israel of taking over the
Lebanese part of rajar a town on the
border between Lebanon and the Israeli
occupied Syrian Golan Heights
Israel's move in hajjar followed a
similar act by Hezbollah the group set
up outposts along the border in an area
claimed by Israel for now there is a
cautious calm but the possible
escalation can't be ruled out
Beirut